Qual è il bagno dei maschi no il bagno
delle femmine ok
e lì
dietro Vedi
Oh no ah parte
preferita di Vitale Benvenuti su Anita
Stories Guardate dove siamo a scuola
abbiamo anche lo zaino Beh Vitale Ma ti
sei dimenticato di mettere la maglietta
in spiaggia
è una maglietta color carne Quella Ma
insomma ecco qua Questo dovrebbe essere
l'insegnante il professore il maestro
Oh mio Dio particolare diciamo
demonizzato dall'insegnante comunque
Escape Room di oggi dovremmo scappare da
questa nuova scuola Che esploriamo un
po' voi ovviamente lasciate un bel mi
piace qua sotto lasciate un mi piace mi
piace vi porterà fortuna a scuola quindi
vi lascio subito mi piace qua e vediamo
un po' come queste Escape Room ti
guiderò attraverso la tua fuga Oh un
grafico via veramente qualcuno che ci
aiuta e non che ci vuole sfracellare
Allora bisogna andare da questa parte
forse Aspetta Qua c'è la classe di
matematica no Io odio
matematica aspetta dice salta Non
toccare la lava quindi forse bisogna
andare di qua Eh sì anche perché qua non
mi fa passare l'intero inglese senza Uh
Chi prenderà per prima il badge L'Italia
è già Bubu punto già dopo davanti
alla scuola Ciao C'è una alunno lì
aperto Poverino lo vedi
Poverino è rimasto lì una mano eh non so
se ci riesco vediamo
No aiuto ah ah come sempre prima mi
cadono i capelli ragazzi ma perché
divento pelata e poi cado Io comunque
sto andando al SuperEnalotto
lì Boh non lo so 26 Vabbè dov'è andato
Vitale mi pento e io sono già passato
avanti Speriamo ci sia un labirinto così
invitare rimani incastrato e non troverò
la mia No io sono la classe di inglese
allora che cosa dice qua Ah un altro
giocatore di inglese Sì inglese lo adoro
Basta su questi su questi mobili per
arrivare dall'altra parte non toccare
l'acqua Ti ho visto che sei scomparso
non è giusto e c'è una fontana lì sopra
alla scuola normale noi tutte le scuole
certo
gli studenti e farli crescere
tanto sempre aiuto cioè lo spelling Wow
Ecco Vitale la doccia Ciao ciao Così
impari a superarmi Ora ti superò io non
ti aspetto Ciao
io sono passato ormai
a scuola vediamo qual è la prossima
classe
[Musica]
Io sono nell'aula di scienze addio non
mi raggiungerai mai Sì sì tanto adesso
di sfracelli salta sopra i tubi chimici
Ah molto bene
ma perché mi dici salta sopra se mai
esito Sì salta Aldi sopra Forse
intendeva Eccovi Eh vai via delle
persone senza maglietta qua Vai via
molto attento a non farti colpire delle
esplosioni chimiche Wow È normale avere
le esplosioni chimiche e anche a scuola
no Certo Certo
bisogna ingrandire un po' Ecco Vitale
laggiù aiuto raggiungiamolo Ciao
E ora salta non colpire l'acqua Beh
Giustamente sì con l'acqua si colpisce
ancora
Google
qua c'è un foglio con scritto Sei
sospeso
Eh c'è di nuovo quella sorta di
professore alunno demoniato con i fari
laser Il presidente è arrabbiato la
evitate eh prenditi questo Vedi bisogna
Saltare su sui libri però bisogna anche
evitare la si- no Ma tu hai capito come
si fa no
sempre
Ciao ciao preside non mi hai preso
Qual è il trucco qual è il trucco
saltare
Ciao ciao Vado a prendere il Belgio
Scegli un bagno qualcuno ti aiuterà
succede se scelgo il bagno dei maschi
invece che delle Femmine vediamo che
questo sbloccato qui aiuta il bagno Ehi
mi fai entrare nel bagno dei maschi vai
No no no voglio andare al bagno delle
femmine e vediamo
Ciao
Qual è il bagno dei maschi no bagno
delle femmine Ok
cosa puoi entrare qua
dietro vai via il bagno c'è scritto oh
no oh no Ah ah ah ah ah
Comunque non l'iPhone No vabbè Questo
puzza di attraversarlo
Dobbiamo saltare
meglio guarda guarda guarda
che schifo
Qualcuno ha lasciato cadere i loro
materiali scolastici saltali Ok Dove Ah
ah Vitale in testa
Mmm caffetteria bene impazzito Non
toccare le sue cadute
Ciao ciao
C'è qualcosa da mangiare qua inciampato
per evitare qualsiasi
ti darò un panino Vai vai dietro il
balcone vai
Aspetta dietro il balcone
Ma perché hanno cambiato il suono di
Roblox quando muori Era così bello Ve lo
ricordate
qua non si passa dove andate vernice
dall'altra parte c'è Ciao Che bello La
classe B La parte verniciata la
verniciava tutta ah ah tanto bene Sono
tornata in testa no chi vincerebbe
secondo voi io Vitale
[Musica]
Che cos'è questo tè Che cos'è evita di
farti colpire dalle palle da basket Ah
ok sicura che qua Vitale morirà sempre
così
sta arrivando Non vedo l'ora di vedere
Vitale qualche volta
ok non lo dico più non dico niente Ah
ecco Anita
Sì ce l'ho fatta Ora vediamo votare
quante volte viene sfracellata
ma proprio all'ultimo però
non si fa così no Ah ah ah
dai prendetelo prendete
Ah Ah Ah va bene
in continuazione No no ce l'ho fatta
no
nero di là Ciao ciao Sono tornata
indietro adesso che proviamo qua Uh cosa
sto facendo vediamo ancora la vita
non farti colpire dalla loro spazzatura
Ah ci stanno buttando la spazzatura
[Musica]
veramente dov'è
no no no no no no no no no no devo
prendere prima io devo prendere il
campetto da calcio non lasciare che i
giocatori di calcio ti colpiscono
l'ultima palla bene ma questo non è
calcio
Football
scriveteci pure nei commenti che sport è
questo Aspetta aspetta aspetta non mi
dire quel tronco farà male Se ti
colpisce saltaci sopra va bene Qual è il
tronco questo
freddo Ti ho superata rivincita Proviamo
subito un'altra Escape Room Allora
abbiamo tre Escape Room scappa dal gatto
grasso scappa dagli animali cattivi e
scappa dalla Frecciarossa Dov'è il gatto
grasso Ok proviamo il gatto grasso
vediamo entra
quaments later allora questa volta devo
vincere io non è possibile che invitava
a prendere il Belgio prima di me
attenzione allora di vedere il gatto
grasso
ormai ragazzi
stanno inventando qualsiasi cosa
[Musica]
Che carino il gatto mangione
ma ovviamente se il gatto grasso ci
mangerà Il mio amico gatto mangione
allora dai basta prima tu
ce la sta facendo ah ah
devo andare prima io dal gatto grasso
Eccolo
sicuramente ci mangerà
No qua c'è la zampa gigante del gatto
grasso Oh Qui ci sono tutti i giochini
del gatto palline di lana Guarda c'è la
zampa gigante che scende bisogna stare
attenti a non essere presi dal gatto Uhm
ti ha preso Oh
ehm ho una brutta notizia per te mamma
Guarda che bello come hanno fatto la
bocca del gatto l'hanno fatta meglio
perché è più allungata con i denti
affilati Dove sei andato Eh sono stato
inghiottito dal gatto
no il gatto c'ha degli ossicini qua
dentro Poi c'ha Non lo so che cos'è
quello aiuto Hehehe beh meno male non
l'hanno messo come negli altri Escape
Room che mangiano le lattine qua perché
ho ha mangiato tipo la scacchiera della
dama ma ho mangiato il ketchup e
maionese Ma perché
ragazzi non c'entra niente no spregelato
sì ritorna in testa questa volta devo
prenderlo io prima il badge Mmm vedremo
i biscotti No ma infatti non posso
mangiare biscotti col cioccolato
Chissà
ho la gola Oh levati di vetro perché hai
la maglietta qua è perché ho messo
questo gioco lo riconosce Forse son
quell'altro non lo riconosceva dove
siamo qua e questo è forse la pipì del
gatto non mi dire che siamo già in
qualsiasi siamo già in quel punto lì
Attenzione attenzione
Il gatto ha mangiato le bacchette intere
Eh dai non era molto difficile Comunque
siamo finiti nella lettiera del gatto lo
vedi il gatto qui è un gatto grassone Oh
Voglio vederlo Beh hehehe Che cosa hai
fatto Anita
sfracellato esattamente Che cos'è uno
spazzolino Ah tutto il gatto ma cosa
c'entra Oh che carino Guardate ah ah il
gatto ciccione carino
No Non ti azzardare a prendere il Belgio
capito
il gabinetto eh nel gabinetto Ci sono
alcuni gatti che sono trainati per farla
nel gabinetto
sono un po' strani certo del gabinetto
Ah quindi non dobbiamo salire noi gabbie
dobbiamo attraversare questa parte Blu
però io continuo a sfracellarmi ciao
ciao ciao
sopra la carta igienica
Facebook dove sei Io sono sullo carta
igienica
tanto la devo prendere devo prendere io
il Belgio il lavandino sta facendo il
bagno al gatto forse attenta c'era una
presa elettrica
dobbiamo andare da questa parte
Ah dobbiamo tornare giù dici vediamo
forse dobbiamo andare nella presa
gialla
Ok arrivo
e dove sei finito nei cavi elettrici Ma
come Sì ci sono i cavi elettrici
[Musica]
no no no no no non può prendere invece
nuovamente evitare questa volta ma cosa
c'entra questo cavi elettrici col gatto
ciccione ciao ciao ciao caduto
sfracellato lì per terra eh devi rifare
da noi nel frattempo vado a prendere il
meglio
ora vi ho detto orecchini di oggi
abbiamo due belle fette di anguria
avvolto da una 10 nei commenti mi piace
belle fresche di quest'estate E poi
negli altri video vi ho detto date un
voto da 1 a 10 agli orecchini così poi
Sceglieremo i vincitori quelli con più
voti però voi date sempre voto 10 voto
10.000 date un voto da 1 a 10 non sempre
10 perché sennò vinceranno tutti gli
orecchini perché mi piacciono tutti vuol
dire che sono tutti bellissimi allora
Dai sbrigati sbrigati sono qui che ti
sta aspettando ne approfitta che io mi
metto a parlare con voi per superarli mi
sono scongelato sulla pancia questo
ok Siamo sotto al mobile noi siamo
piccolissimi
[Applauso]
Troppo carino quale porta Io prendo
questa sei morta no Ok allora ti seguo
ma come sarà questa adesso
e ora proviamo questa è scelto
Ok
carino non sembra molto amichevole
sembra che ci vogliamo mangiare
Mmm Qua c'è una freccia Ehi che c'è Dove
stai cadendo
siamo in cucina
Oh Che carini Ma com'è possibile che ci
sono dei brufoli grandi più piccoli di
una formica in questo gioco perché è
tutto gigante
Aspetta aspetta che si muovono
[Musica]
il lavandino con le stoviglie Che bello
vado a vedere le cose tutti i giganti il
topo qua ha la coda gigante Brava allora
proviamo a saltare e adesso no no no
Aiuto Sono passato Sei riuscito a
passare adesso già avanti sto prendendo
il Belgio Oh come invece no non è vero
non è vero
però sono molto avanti non si vede
ancora nuda Aspetta che cos'è cioè
marmellata ciao ciao ciao
è diventato più bravo di ogni giorno non
so come Uffa Oh che bello stiamo
saltando su dei barattoli ci sa qualcosa
da mangiare qua dentro Sì bravo Fatti
distrarre dal cibo
Qui c'è qualcosa ho visto del cioccolato
No non è vero è la spazzatura questa
pensavo fosse cioccolato invece noia
Come hai fatto a confondere la
spazzatura col cioccolato Eh perché è
tutto uguale qui però mi sono
sfracellato Mmm no ho bisogno mi devo
sbrigare Mi sa che ho visto che è vicino
al peggio Oh no devo andare devo andare
eh Sono caduto dentro la spazzatura
andare Beh giù dal posto giusto invece
lo vedete lo vedete
Speriamo che Vitale si faccia più
giocare È lì dietro Vitale lì dietro
no vai via Vai via è l'ultimo esploso il
momento ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
vero vero vero
l'ho preso Aspetta
sono inciampato sull'ultimo non è giusto
giusto
Vediamo se riuscirà a prenderlo Vediamo
ce l'ho fatta Ci siamo pari 1-1 Vabbè
lasciate un bel mi piace per vedere
altre Escape Room E ora vi lasciamo su
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao